[Music]
Shannen purser is known for her role as
barb on stranger things but since then
she also got a role in Riverdale and
Leonard the main role in Sierra Burgess
is a loser
this young Hollywood star is definitely
keeping busy but wait until you hear
about the number one thing that makes
her so incredibly brave and
inspirational don't forget to hit that
notification bell to never miss another
video and be sure to check out our
community section for even more fun now
let's check out some facts about Shannon
purser her first paid role was stranger
things
Shannon's acting CV is pretty impressive
for someone whose first role was on
stranger things Barb's just a supportive
role but the impact Shannon created with
her character was unreal she also says
it's pretty surreal to see a supportive
role take off so massively what can we
say barb really was one of the most
relatable characters on stranger things
and it's amazing to see Shannon's career
take off the way it did it's an
inspiration for all the spiring
actresses sometimes it really just takes
one role and your life changes forever
Riverdale her role is barb was so
powerful and iconic it also landed her
another role on another popular TV show
this really bad thing is happening and
there's nothing that I can do to stop it
Shannon didn't really know much about
the Archie comics or Riverdale before
the role but yet again she managed to
portray a fun favorite character
Shannon's also been teasing when Ethel
mugs will look like in season three of
the show and according to her we're in
for quite a dark surprise she said that
season three will feature a lot more of
Ethel and we have no doubt it's because
of Shannon's ability to make just about
any character a fan fave nominated for a
Primetime Emmy imagine having your very
first role and getting nominated for a
Primetime Emmy for it Barba's had such
an impact on stranger things that all of
Hollywood started paying attention to
Shannon how cool is that she was
nominated in 2017 as an outstanding
guest actress in a drama series
specifically for episode holly-jolly
although she didn't win it just once
again shows that her acting talent
really does speak for itself you never
know
when you're acting role will become a
huge inspiration Shannon definitely
didn't expect that any of her roles
would be so well received
she's completely inspirational seriously
if you check out any of Shannon's
interviews you'll notice that this
beautiful lady also has an incredibly
beautiful mind she's a fantastic role
model and a total inspiration for young
Hollywood in one of her interviews she
said that people easily write off
teenagers and Millennials and think of
them as completely shallow she also
outlined the importance of knowing that
being a teenager is actually really hard
and that people totally underestimate
how strong they are for dealing with so
many emotions at once
she loves talking about real-life
situations and making people around her
aware of the importance of kindness and
compassion amazing social media accounts
if you're not yet following Shannon on
social media you really should she's
extremely active on Instagram but
Twitter is the platform where you could
find exactly how she feels and what she
thinks about various situations she's a
serious mental health advocates but her
tweets also bring tons of humor you
really need to check it out we have a
feeling she'll get totally booked out
and forget about Twitter in a few years
so make sure you enjoy her tweets while
you're still getting a decent amount of
them she's a total hashtag inspiration
people know her as barb
Shannon laughed when she said no one
really knows her real name a ton of
people actually call her barb she said
she had directors on new projects who
called her barb and apparently even her
mom accidentally used the wrong name how
crazy is that she said that she answers
to barb most of the time but sometimes
she waits for them to realize their
mistake and what's even crazier is that
people actually think Barb's her real
name he can't blame them even Shannon
herself says that barb is the totally
relatable patron saint of the outcast
she's surprised by her own fame it's
rare that an actress will audition for a
single role and have that role massively
take off but with the rise of Netflix
series and reboots we're seeing this
happen more and more
still Shannon was very surprised by her
own fame which is completely normal
considering she appeared in plenty of
supporting roles that that weren't meant
to really take off she said in herself
that she never expected this to happen
and no one really knew
whether or not stranger things would
become popular to be fair you usually
can never tell until you actually
release your work inspired by 80s
fashion we all know Barb's a fan of the
80s fashion but how does Savannah phew
about it she said that she clearly
remembers first trying out Barb's
wardrobe and being totally shocked that
people would actually wear that in the
80s
times definitely have changed haven't
they since then she realized that she
could put a modern spin on a lot of
Barb's wardrobe and that every piece
barb has worn is actually really cute
she also said that the wardrobe
department really wanted to make sure
they give barb the authentic 80s look
and feel and by the looks of it they got
it right but do you think we'll ever see
barb whoops we mean Shannon we're 80s
clothing outside of her role she used to
work at a movie theater when Fame
unexpectedly hits you you have to quit
whatever part-time job you're working at
especially if you're dealing with public
Shannon said that she used to work at a
movie theater and she even did it when
stranger things first debuted of course
as an actor you never know whether or
not your show will be popular so a lot
of actors do indeed have part-time jobs
but Shannon had to quit her movie
theater job when people started
recognizing her and it completely
disrupted her day-to-day
responsibilities she's truly living her
best life now isn't she she's a huge
science-fiction fan one reason why
Shannon accepted her role in stranger
things is because she fell in love with
the little glimpses of the story she
managed to see when she first read the
script she didn't get the full story
until after her audition but because
she's a huge science fiction fan she
fell in love with the paper version of
the series she also said that she loves
movies from the 80s so seeing a
combination of both in a single project
really made her totally fall in love
with stranger things and based on the
amount of international fans stranger
things has she wasn't the only one she
picked up TV acting pretty quickly
Shannon is actually used to theater
acting so before she had her first TV
debut she spent a lot of time acting in
theater but still acting in front of TV
cameras is actually pretty different
from acting on stage but luckily for her
her theater experience is the reason why
she was able to pick up TV roles so
quickly
and really deliver her best besides not
acting live basically allowed her to do
a retake and correct her mistakes but
being a theatre actress was definitely a
wonderful advantage to her career and it
definitely paid off
she's an open book shannon has many
endearing qualities that will make you
fall in love with her but one of the
biggest is without a doubt the fact that
she's pretty much an open book she
doesn't hold back her feelings and she's
a huge advocate when it comes to mental
health you can already see that from her
social media posts but she's also no
stranger to speaking about mental health
in her interviews seeing our idols go
through some of the same mental
struggles as ourselves is extremely
important and Shannon is definitely
aware that she can make a positive
impact by sharing her own personal
struggles we love her she's from Atlanta
and so is stranger things
Shannon was raised in Atlanta and in one
of her interviews she talked about how
that had an advantage with her role as
barb she was also in her senior year of
high school which contributed to being
able to portray a relatable character as
this was her first role living in
Atlanta was definitely an advantage as
she got to come home from work at the
end of the day and talk about her job to
her parents that way the transition into
the world of Hollywood wasn't as
stressful and intense
sounds like a balance most young actors
could only dream of she didn't know what
would happen to barb if you haven't
watched stranger things just yet skip
ahead to a couple of seconds of this
video to avoid any spoilers because
we're about to tell you what happens to
barb
seriously skip ahead 3 2 1 now barb dies
you probably knew that unless you're a
rebel and you haven't clicked away in
that case sorry but we warned you and as
it turns out none of the cast knew about
this because they hadn't received the
scripts Shannon says that the actual
spoiler came from one of her makeup
artists who said that they'll have to
test death makeup on her because she's
not going to make it as a character of
course she loves her co-workers
Hollywood used to be full of drama
between cast members they didn't like
each other
there were hookups and sometimes the
drama carried on for years but young
Hollywood is setting a new friendship
trend and were totally here for it
Shannon admitted that she loves every
single member of
castes from both stranger things and
River Dell she looks like she's very fun
to be around so we have no doubt that
everyone loves her - do you prefer
Hollywood drama or seeing people get
along let us know in the comments the
audition process for stranger things was
easy everyone always wonders what
auditions look like but in Shannon's
case it was actually pretty easy she
said that she was quite familiar with
auditions because of her previous
experience in theater but she always got
close calls and never really booked
anything and tells stranger things came
along she got an email from the show
asking her for an audition tape she sent
it in and got a response back that they
wanted her to come in and read for the
duffer brothers they emailed her the
very same day and told her she got the
parts and the rest is history she has
amazing life philosophies Shannon might
be young but she already holds a lot of
wisdom she realized the importance of
being relatable and she makes sure she
conveys that in every single role she
has she said that working on stranger
things was her chance to show everyone
what she can do what are we doing here
and put her heart soul and passion into
her character she has gratitude and
always is thankful for her experiences
it's those philosophies that allow her
to keep on winning and really bringing
every single role to life and we have a
feeling of her role in Sierra Burgess as
a loser will be just as iconic as any
other because of that she plays piano
many Hollywood stars have multiple
talents that enable them to stand out
from the crowd and Shannon is no
exception did you know that she can
actually play piano she did a cover of
one of Lord's songs on Instagram and it
was actually amazing we love an actress
who's also a triple threat and from what
it looks like Shannon could definitely
sing a song or two what do you think
doesn't this show off her amazing talent
for performing even more we have a
feeling we'll be seeing her and at least
one musical and we already can't wait
her dream role is in Eleanor & Park it
pretty much looks like the sky's the
limit for Shannon but if she could land
any Hollywood role what would it be she
said that she'd absolutely loved to play
Eleanor in a book
called Eleanor & Park from Rainbow
Rowell things got exciting when
DreamWorks picked up the rights but
ended up giving them back to the author
which means that the production deal
fell through
she said that Eleanor pretty much looks
like her and she absolutely loves the
story you never know maybe someone will
give the book and Shannon a chance she's
there for teens that struggle with their
sexualities we know that Shannon is
absolutely inspiring and she's a huge
mental health advocate but in August
2018 Shannon came out as a bisexual and
announced that she's there for those who
feel alone we told you she's the
sweetest she said that she would love to
get society to the point where sexuality
doesn't matter but because that's not
the case she wants to make sure her fans
know that they're allowed to love
whoever they want she also revealed that
her fans frequently contact her and she
helps them open up about their own
sexuality she really is a complete
inspiration and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]